grecia y la crisis en la unión europea
ha estado en las noticias por un rato
entonces pues ya tiene rato que hice un
vídeo acerca de eso y ahorita voy a
hacer otro pero para darse un poquito de
contexto porque puede ser que veas es
decir este vídeo muy en el futuro este
lo estoy haciendo en mayo de 2012
entonces realmente no sé qué tan viejo
sea para ti pero bueno espero que en
este vídeo y en los siguientes te pueda
plantear los escenarios que se ven desde
ahorita y qué riesgos y qué debilidades
pueden tener mira esto de acá esto es
grecia entonces vamos a pensar ahorita
desde un punto de vista como es como muy
general en la situación en la que se
encuentran mira si vemos este cuadro de
aquí abajo lo más obvio se ve en el
primer renglón y aquí es que la deuda
pública está creciendo dramáticamente
año con año y aquí abajo en la deuda
contra el producto interno bruto lo cual
es importante verdad porque puedes tener
una deuda grande pero si tu producción
compensa eso puede que no sea un
problema el problema es cuando debes
mucho más de lo que puedes producir lo
que vemos aquí en el renglón de deuda a
producto interno bruto es que la deuda
comparada con este producto
muy por arriba de 100% mira muy por
arriba desde 2008 y podemos ver que una
gran parte de eso es porque el ingreso
público o sea lo de los impuestos es
consistentemente más bajo que los gastos
déjame escribirlo por aquí porque eso es
importante entonces tenemos los
impuestos que los impuestos son menor
que el gasto eso lleva a déficits un
déficit es simplemente pues cuando no
pudiste pagar o más bien cuánto estás
gastando más de lo que estás ganando
entonces si hay un déficit año con año
eso quiere decir que cada año va a
aumentar la deuda porque la deuda es la
cantidad de dinero que debes que esta
línea de acá y entonces esto a lo que
lleva fíjate es a los gente lleva a que
se aumente la deuda se aumenta la deuda
pero eso no es el único problema porque
conforme la deuda aumenta y aumenta más
entonces las personas empiezan a
preocuparse más de la situación de
grecia para ver si realmente le pueden
pagar verdad o sea si sus pagarés si son
buenos y esta preocupación que causan
pues como la deuda del gobierno aumenta
y se hace más riesgosa
las personas empiezan a pedir una tasa
de interés más alta entonces si la deuda
aumenta entonces las personas piensan
que grecia no es bueno para prestarle
dinero entonces le piden un alto interés
interés sube y esto hace que las cosas
sean todavía peor verdad porque mira
ahorita ya tenemos déficits porque
estamos gastando más de lo que tenemos
en impuestos pero ahora hay que gastar
todavía más en el interés de nuestra
deuda por ejemplo si tenemos una tasa de
interés del 10% por un préstamo de
10.000 millones de pesos entonces al
aumentar en 5 por ciento ese interés ya
son 5 mil millones de pesos más en
gastos por interés eso claramente es un
golpecito fuerte de interés y por tanto
se va a aumentar la deuda todavía más
eso está súper horrible verdad bueno
justo grecia está en esta situación y
podrías decir bueno pues parece ser que
la solución es muy sencillita verdad
porque no simplemente lo que hace grecia
es haber vamos a hacer una combinación
entre aumentar impuestos le voy a poner
aquí aumentar y tal vez un poco más
importante porque no además de eso
disminuyen disminuyen
su gasto y bueno osea si podría ser pero
el primer pero es la situación política
porque este gasto de acá este gasto que
está apuntado aquí pueden ser promesas
del gobierno hacia la persona son
pensiones son proyectos gubernamentales
son varios tipos de inversiones que la
gente ya prometió al pueblo si
disminuyes el dinero que está gastando
sea y entonces las personas que están
aprovechando esos programas pues no se
van a quedar sentadas de brazos
políticamente es una decisión pésima
pero bueno sabes que o sea si podría
haber un líder muy valiente que dijera
bueno yo me voy a aventar a cortar el
gasto gubernamental pero aunque hubiera
esta persona puede ser que no sea una
buena idea deja te cuento esto de acá
mira vámonos a este renglón que es el
crecimiento del producto interno bruto
real y mira grecia está en una recesión
muy severa
yo sé ahorita está generando muy poquito
económicamente sus fábricas están
subutilizadas entonces qué sucede si
hacemos una combinación de esto de
aumentar los impuestos aumentar el
ingreso de impuestos y disminuir el
gasto
pues eso lo que va a hacer es quitarle
el aire a la economía mira hay una
palabra que seguramente has escuchado
antes a esta combinación de factores que
sobre todo se enfoca en disminuir el
gasto de una manera significativa se le
conoce como austeridad austeridad a lo
mejor has escuchado esa palabra antes
verdad algo austero es algo que pues no
sé da muchos lujos que está viviendo
básicamente con las necesidades
primarias y entonces mucha gente dice
grecia sabes que necesitas medidas de
austeridad y si osea ha tenido algunas
pequeñas rondas pero la gente dice sabes
que grecia tienes que dejar de gastar
todavía más el gran problema de esto es
que cortas mucho dinero de la economía
entonces la economía lleva a que la
economía sea lenta
al ente y bueno si la economía sea lenta
pues eso va a pegarle a tus impuestos
verdad o sea que la economía se haga más
lenta hace que tus impuestos disminuyan
verdad que es el ingreso que tienes y
qué sucede pues otra vez está feo verdad
porque eso aumenta todavía más el
déficit porque otra vez la gente dice
sabes que pues ahora tengo una economía
pues más fea sube la tasa de interés y
como el ingreso por impuestos va a
disminuir pero el gasto de mando se va a
mantener fijo o bueno podría incrementar
conforme se mueve la economía por
ejemplo puede aumentar el número de
pensionados y así entonces esto va a
hacer que las cosas estén todavía peor
verdad justo esto es lo que ha sucedido
en los últimos años después vamos a
platicarlo más a profundidad pero más o
menos la idea fue que grecia pidió ayuda
fue con la unión europea y pidió dinero
y a cambio la unión europea dijo bueno
vas te vamos a ayudar pero te debe de
doler y ese dolor que que le intentaron
causar voy a hacerlo o forzar a que
tuviera estas medidas de austeridad pero
qué sucedió eso fue una mala idea porque
de hecho hizo que la economía se
volviera peor y entonces eso lo que
causó fue que deuda contra el producto
interno bruto fuera
más grande porque el producto interno
bruto se contrajo y se contrajo después
de pensar un poco en todos estos asuntos
pues vemos que la solución pues al menos
no es obvia si hacemos políticas de
austeridad entonces eso va a alentar más
la economía va a hacer que vaya más
lento que se vuelva menos productiva al
menos a corto plazo y como si eso no
fuera suficientemente feo además las
políticas de austeridad causan una gran
inestabilidad política son muy
impopulares entre la población lo voy a
dejar ahorita hasta aquí pero en el
siguiente vídeo después de que hayas
meditado un poquito acerca de esto en el
siguiente vídeo lo que voy a platicar es
que haría un país así totalmente
independiente de política y fiscalmente
vamos a ver cuáles serían sus
posibilidades cuáles serían sus
escenarios y después platicaremos un
poco por qué no aplican a la situación
actual de grecia